جذور ويليام في مكان ما
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نظرًا
للطبيعة المبهمة
التي تم التعامل معها مع هذه النتائج ،
سنقدم تفاصيل
عن هذه الطبيعة المفتوحة
قريبًا جدًا ، نحن قلقون للغاية
بشأن المهارات التي ظهرت في
المركز الوطني الإيطالي في كينيا السابقة
وكذلك الانقسام داخل IDC
مما أدى إلى انسحاب بعض المفوضين
من عملية التحول وإصدار
بيانهم الخاص.
ما رأيناه بالأمس
كان مهزلة
وتجاهل صارخ للدستور
وقوانين كينيا من
قبل  السيد شافوكاتي ، أقلية مفوضي إي دي سي
[موسيقى]
، لا يعود الأمر إلينا لتقرير
ما إذا كان السيد بوكاتي قد ارتكب
جريمة ،
ونترك هذا التصميم
للسلطات المختصة
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى
] وأريد أن أعد شعب كينيا
بأنني
سأفعل  إدارة حكومة ديمقراطية منفتحة
وشفافة وسأعمل مع المعارضة
إلى الحد
الذي يوفرون فيه الرقابة
على إدارتي ،
لذلك
لا توجد قاعدة ولا
يوجد أي شيء  ليس هناك مجال للانتقام
ولا مجال
للنظر إلى الوراء
ونحن نتطلع إلى المستقبل